aujourd'hui on célèbre notre faim 50e
oui mais bien par une autochtone
aujourd'hui on a la chance de célébrer
de souligner la 156ème chronique de
parole autochtone et pour ça mais j'ai
ma collègue anne arrivants qui va venir
me poser des questions donc aujourd'hui
je suis encore en vacances
allô oui ça parce que j'ai plein de
questions vont être posées en fait 150
émissions 150 chronique ça veut dire 150
questions est-ce qu'au cours de ses
chroniques là tu as vu des questions
évolué et est ce que les gens ont appris
déjà plein de choses donc les questions
évoluent au fur et à mesure mais il ya
des questions qui sont venus souvent je
pense que des fois c est difficile de
répondre à une question qui est
historique derrière d'une façon pour
l'étude donc des fois la question à
rythme avec une petite différence en
question une évolution fait que j'essaie
de répondre dans cet angle que je sens
qu'il veut être développées mais c'est
aussi difficile de pouvoir donner tout
les détails quand deux trois minutes
pour le faire mais c'est ce qui est
plaisant avec les chroniques c'est qu'on
peut répondre plusieurs fois jusqu'à 150
fois d'ailleurs à des chroniques à des
répondants les questions qui viennent du
public et ça c'est le plus important
c'est que c'est des questions qui
viennent ce public donc c'est des
questions qui sont importants à répondre
alors il n'y a pas de redondance dans
des questions ça arrive et on leur pose
la même question oui on peut me reposer
la même question mais j'avais fait de
pouvoir renforcer sa femme point je
pense que des fois ya des concepts aussi
que dont je discute que n'ayant pas
encore là bas ça que je me rends compte
que je clarifie cette base il faut que
j'explique la loi sur les indiens peu
avant de répondre à la question
et ça ça me permettait de pouvoir
répétés des questions des fois mais je
dirais que c'est souvent très très
changeante ray est très varié au site et
politique culture langue se sait
outsider on voit dans toutes les
directions
oui j'ai d'ailleurs faut que je des fois
je me rafraîchir la mémoire sur
certaines dates sur certains détails
fait que c'est un bon exercice pour moi
aussi est-ce que tu as reçu des
questions qui ont été surprenantes en
fait qui t'ont obligé à te dépasser à
fouiller ou en fait qui t'ont étonné oh
mon dieu
je pense que les questions de langues je
suis vraiment impressionné parce que les
gens veulent vraiment en connaître plus
sur la langue je pense qu'il ya une
sensibilité au québec aussi par rapport
au franc ce qui fait que ça l'a allumée
chez beaucoup de québécois le besoin de
sentir une représentation des langues
autochtones ou les infections des
lingotins moi c'est celle là que j'aime
beaucoup parce que ça demande beaucoup
d'activités une personne de s'intéresser
à la vente de l'autre c'est intéressant
en plus parce qu'on est dans l'année des
langues autochtones l'année
internationale donc ça tombe bien il
faudrait continuer maintenant est ce que
toi tu as appris des choses à travers
les questions compte imposer des choses
que tu ne savais pas en détail ça m'a
fait beaucoup de districts je connais sa
surface des fois je découvrais des
nouveaux détails sur un historique ou
des noms aux dés et je pense que ça m'a
permis moi-même de continuité que comme
quoi je connais avec la science infuse
oui donc j'essaye d'utiliser les
connaissances que j'ai déjà pour
partager pour je dirais simplifiée juste
signé ou ou même éduquer des gens et je
pense que c'est comme tout le monde
aussi je suis en évolution constante et
quand tu attaques tonnes n'est pas
nécessairement avec toutes les
connaissances hautacam donc on est
toujours en progression toujours un
il ya toujours quelque chose à apprendre
jusqu'à la dernière journée où tu m'as
oui et là quelle est la question qu on
ne t'a jamais posé que tu aurais aimé qu
on te pose à quoi de quoi aurait l'air
le futur bar 21
quand je vois un autochtone au futurisme
pour toi de quazar et la roja comme la
pause je vous avais fait à la pause et
d'ailleurs comment je fantasme et le
futur autochtone parce que le loeuff le
futur pour moi est très importante on
parle de cette future génération donc
dans l'imaginaire la narration
autochtone ya pas de fin mais quand on
est riche pas vers une fin destructrice
une apocalypse
on se dirige vers un meilleur futur
toujours fait cc c'est sûr que
j'aimerais c'est que des fois parler
mais ça reste toujours dans l'hypothèse
voilà alors on se revoit dans cinquante
questions
1 pourquoi pas on se lance le défi on
s'en va jusqu'à une 200e et là on va
encore faire un bilan
moment là oui j'espère même qu'on va
avoir des nouveaux chroniqueurs parce
que je pense qu'il n'y a pas une seule
voix autochtone c'est pour ça qu'on aime
sa voix au docteur louis
j'espère voir des jeunes qui vont
découvrir une petite faible de vouloir
connaître leur culture en parler le
partager avec les autres à vulgariser
j'espère avoir d'autres questions aussi
gêné vous pas ce qu'ils font de ce que
j'entends toujours un bon feedback
quand je suis sur le terrain quand
j'arrive je rencontre des gens du
gouvernement et j'écoute des chroniques
same as vraiment beaucoup dans mon
travail
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on fait
vraiment un travail d'intérêt public
puis ça ça aide à la relation ça a aidé
à la réconciliation
alors j'ai beaucoup d'espoir on va
multiplier ces voix là puis qu'on peut
répondre à plus de questions encore la
merci mais l'islam y